[Music]
let's go out to Idaho and talk to Ryan
what's up
Ryan how we doing partying dude what are
you up
to just living in living another day
there you go it's better than the
alternative what's up man yeah very sure
so my question for you is how do I know
when I need to put my family
and or my wife on the back burner for a
season um family's easier wife is
another story what's going on right so
over the last few years you know I've I
mean I'm not I shouldn't say I'm not
much of a social person because I am but
just lately I've been kind of wanting to
start dreaming and start doing
more and but I get you know like family
members and or my wife they're like no
you you don't want to do that you're
going to want to do this or you don't
want to go there you're going to want to
come here give me an example of what
you're talking about so like being debt
free um a year ago I took a weekend for
myself to really try to figure out what
I wanted to do and how I wanted to do it
because I was tired of I'm tired of
living paycheck to paycheck um back in
2015 I or back at the end of 2014 I was
debt free completely I just like all
right I'm going to go I'm going to get
into my career I'm going to do the
things that I want to do and just make a
great life out of it um you know and I
was in discussion with my mom and my
mom's just like well you're single so
you know date a girl for a year you know
and see where that thing goes and then
you know after a year or whatever you
know you guys get married well in early
2015 I met a girl we had a great time
met her family and within three months
of knowing each other four months of
knowing each other we are engaged in by
June we were you know June of that year
we were married okay things were great I
was living life you know things were
going well and then all of a sudden you
know I mean we have a good relationship
between each other um which is you know
it's not that's not the bad thing it's
just that our my debt-free status went
from 100% to hey we need to go to the
store and buy this we need to go to the
store and buy that we need to do this or
we need to do that and I you know okay
you're right you know happy wife happy
life that's stupid
advice right and so I mean and so and
the years have gone by but with just
within the last
year I've really gotten tired of living
paycheck to paycheck and having that
status on me and I was so happy and then
you know I got your uh on your past
change your future book and I was just I
mean that book like literally woke me up
I'm like all right I'm going to do this
I'm going to go here these are the plans
I'm going to make you know I'm going to
include the
wife and you know include my family and
show them you know what this is all
about and I get kind
of well I mean it was great then but
maybe not now or let's just do this
let's just do that let me let me cut let
me cut you off number one your family's
out of the picture they don't get a vote
okay how old are you I'm
40 and I think I mean let just so let me
for that reason it's for a long time I'm
the I I'm in the middle child child of
my family I am too and for the longest
time and for the longest time my
family's always put me on the back bur
or told me you know let's not do this or
let's not do that kind of why do you
keep asking your
family because I I want their approval I
guess okay that's on you quit blaming
them right you keep going to them and
they keep giving you advice that's
killing you it's suffocating you and
you're mad at them
yeah why don't give them that they don't
get that power look dude I love my dad
he's
amazing and I love my mom she's
incredible my great great grandkids will
talk about those two right and I didn't
ask him about moving to Nashville I
didn't ask him about becoming the Dena
students at a law school I didn't ask
him about the job before that you know
why they don't get a vote it's my
job yes right
right I did ask my wife right and and
let me tell you this my conversation
with my wife had very little to do with
I want to do this job over that
job it had to do with I'm
dying or her more specifically saying
I'm watching my husband
die right is there something else you
can
do and that is very different than I
want a status of being debt-free I could
give a crap about any status of any kind
what I want is
freedom and part of
Freedom part of this idea that I can
kind of do what I want within the bounds
of the law part of that is because I
don't owe anybody any money right but I
don't want the status of debt free yeah
similar I wanted to write a good book I
wanted actually I didn't I didn't care
that about that as much as I want people
to have more peaceful lives and I'm sick
of the the mental health narrative
that's out there and so right I have a
show so I wrote a book and when I sat
down to write a book I decided I want to
write a good book and I wanted it man it
made me feel good when I got the
call from the the text message from Dave
Ramsey telling me dude your book just
went number one that was awesome right
and that's not a status I was trying to
get you know why because that status
lasts about 30 seconds
mhm but having people all over the
country say and all over the world
actually say dude I had a conversation
with my wife that I've never had right
I'm going to counseling for that that's
awesome but my guess is you've never sat
down with your wife and said honey I
can't
breathe and I I I and I'll be honest
with you I have tried and she's just
like well maybe we need to do this
differently or maybe we need to do that
differently and I'm like okay let's do
it but then like I you know I mean like
for example a year ago I took a weekend
to myself to really kind of just you
know okay this you know kind of make a
plan took the weekend I came back and I
sat down with my wife and I said look
this is need this needs to change and
this needs to change and she just kind
of okay and nothing's changed well and
so to this point what what did you tell
her needed to change I just said that I
just we need to be a little bit more you
know we need to get on a budget we need
to okay that's where you went wrong work
together you disappeared for a weekend
and you came back with a plan for
her true when you go away for a weekend
I come back and I just did
this I didn't take a full weekend but I
got away for a day after basically being
out of pocket for a year writing a book
selling a book being on the road being
all over the place and got super sick
and I was out laid out for a week and
then I had an event and then I was
immediately back on the road I took a
day right and then I circled back you
know what I told my
wife here's what I need to do moving
forward for this upcoming
season okay and that way she didn't have
to fight me because I didn't look at her
and say you're going to need to start
doing this this this and this right see
the difference yeah I do you my friend
have to take some
ownership okay and that might look like
honey I refuse I'm just not going to
borrow money anymore because I can't
breathe okay if you choose to borrow
money we need to have deeper
conversations about our marriage because
whenever I
say I can't breathe and you say well I'm
going to buy this anyway it feel feels
like that thing you're buying has more
value to me than I do more value to you
than I do right every bit of that
conversation is not about what she's
doing it's about how you
feel those are two different things see
what I'm saying right yeah but your
parents stop asking
them right and if they say hey man why
are you hey Mom Dad I'm 40 I got to
start making some of these calls on on
my own I appreciate you I love
you right you know um right I bought
your your newest book and you know on
that bundle and when I saw that video I
mean I've watched that video constantly
which one and the that uh thing you give
they gave that you talked about oh
gotcha gotcha the four things choosing
Freedom yeah yeah um and I shared that
with my mom and you know I sent it to
her and I said hey you got to watch it
well about a month later she we were we
were on the phone and she's just like I
can't believe
it I said what she's like you were
totally right and I said what do you
mean she goes like I've had to watch I
mean I've listened to that thing and
I've watched that thing like a dozen or
so times now and I was just like it's
that's what's changing this whole
attitude of my life that's changing my
direction and she goes well I I will
approve with anything you want to do cuz
you know that's she doesn't get your
approval no no I mean I'm not saying the
approval I'm just saying the fact that
I'm headed that way whether you like it
or not kind of a thing and she goes you
needed to do this a long time ago and I
was just like well of course I did
awesome kind of a thing good but it was
just it was great to hear that my mom's
just like I have to listen to that thing
over and over again because you know
what I don't have to have everybody at
the house you know I don't have to and
know she's on her own adventure
dude if she comes to you and 6 months or
a year and says hey I see you're glowing
I see you laugh a lot more I see every
time we go to dinner now you pick up the
check and you pay for it in
cash I see you saying hey we're not
going to be able to do how holidays this
year or we're only buying one gift a
person everybody make
peace because that's what we're
doing I had that by the way I had that
conversation with my son this morning
for breakfast I'm recording this show on
a Tuesday I had that that conversation
this morning hey by the way son this
year we're just going to do two nice
things and I've already got them and
we're going to do a couple of neat like
adventures and that's going to be
Christmas and he smiled and goes You'
said that the last two years and I go I
know but this year I'm being for real
and he goes that sounds great but I had
that conversation with my son today you
know why he didn't get a vote he doesn't
get a
vote but his mom does
yes it probably felt it probably felt
validating and you felt Vindicated when
your mom said man you were right we
should have done this a long time
ago she doesn't get a vote when she's
telling you you you don't want to do
that she also doesn't get a vote when
she tells you oh you're so right son
because you're still going to her for
approval it's
cool but dude You' got to stop seeking
your mom's approval you're 40 you have
to decide how do I want my house to feel
when when I walk
in what am I going to take ownership I'm
going to take ownership of how I feel in
my thoughts and my actions period honey
I can't ever borrow another dollar
again and if you
do I'm going to feel like the image that
you're trying to hold up is more
important than me being able to sleep
all night or be intimate with you or to
be at peace with our kids or whatever's
going
on will you walk this with
me hang on the line I'm going to send
you Financial Peace University I'm going
to send you the courses the nine week
the nine lessons here's what I want you
to do here's my Challenge and I'm in one
of those lessons or maybe two of those
lessons here's my challenge I want you
to ask her would you be willing to watch
these videos with me just be willing to
watch them with
me it would mean the world to me if you
did
that give that a shot and here's the
deal she might say no no and if she says
no your marriage is in bigger trouble
than you think it is cuz y'all need to
have that conversation that something of
super value super importance she's like
nah I'd rather have a
Suburban I'd rather have a suburban and
a dead
husband then a used whatever and a
husband who laughs a lot and is full of
joy and has retirement and doesn't owe
anybody any money I'd rather I'd rather
the shyy thing now thanks so y'all got
bigger issues bigger fish to fry my
guess
is my super guess is
Ryan she's sick of playing second to
your mom at
40 if you start the conversation with I
have been hanging on to my mom and dad's
approval for so long I'm done with it
from this point forward it's just you
and me she might just melt into a puddle
on the
floor I'd start there thanks for the
call my brother
see